costa rica enfrenta el momento más
difícil en toda la pandemia la semana
pasada fue la que registró mayor número
de casos nuevos en 14 meses y este
miércoles hubo dos mil 434 casos la
cifra de casos diarios más alta desde
que inició la emergencia sanitaria
estamos a las puertas de la peor
catástrofe sanitaria en la historia del
país ha dicho el gerente médico de la
caja costarricense del seguro social las
camas de cuidados intensivos estaban
hasta el miércoles a una capacidad del
94 por ciento el colapso del sistema
sanitario es inminente aseguran
especialistas mientras tanto la caja de
seguridad social busca alternativas como
negociar con hospitales privados para
que atiendan a pacientes con otras
enfermedades y así liberar espacios en
los públicos
el presidente carlos alvarado pidió a la
población no salir de sus casas a menos
que fuese urgente pero no se decretara
en nuevos cierres sino solamente una
ampliación de la restricción vehicular
mientras tanto 800 mil personas han sido
vacunadas contra la cob y 19 en un país
de 5 millones de habitantes pero ello no
ha sido suficiente para impedir esta
tercera ola